Let's talk about the three fats that
have the potential to reverse a fatty
liver. So many people are
freaked out about fat and they have this
thing in their mind that if they eat any
fat at all, they're going to get a fatty
liver. But in reality, what causes fatty
liver is more of the carbohydrates that
are converting to fat. But there are
three fats that you can start consuming
in larger amounts that will help reverse
a fatty liver. And I'm going to put some
links down below for each one. Number
one, olive oil. Olive oil is an omega-9
fatty acid. It's anti-inflammatory and
it's highly beneficial to support a
fatty liver. Don't worry about the
calories from olive oil or trying to
have just a little bit. Uh, use a good
amount of it. There's a lot of other
benefits to olive oil and I'll put a
link down below, but I would recommend
organic and extra virgin olive oil being
the best. All right, number two, fish
oils. So, I'm talking about wild caught
fish oils. You can also do cod liver oil
rich in omega-3. Fish oils inhibit fat
from accumulating on the liver and it
can actually help reduce the fat in your
liver as well. It's highly
anti-inflammatory. It's also good for
the retina. It's good for the heart and
it's definitely good for your brain. So,
make sure that you start consuming fish
at least two to three times a week, but
make sure it's the fatty fish as well.
And it wouldn't hurt to find a high
quality fish oil or a cod liver oil. All
right, last one is the virgin coconut
oil can help reverse a fatty liver in
rat studies. Now, there's not any human
studies, but if you have a pet rat that
has a fatty liver, start feeding them
some coconut oil. Make sure it's virgin.
Now, there's some other things you can
do to reduce fat on the liver. And by
the way, having a fatty liver is very,
very common. One way to know that you
have it is just to look down. If you
have a gut, you have a fatty liver. But
even if you don't have a gut and you're
doing a high carbohydrate diet, um the
fat is around the organs. You can't
quite see them sometimes and it's
definitely going to be crammed up inside
the liver. There's some other things you
can do. Purified bile uh salts is a
really good remedy for a fatty liver.
You take uh one tablet after a meal.
Number two, choline. excellent fats
soluble um nutrient that can help strip
fat off the liver. Also, cutting your
carbs down, and I'm talking about sugar
and especially fructose because there's
nothing that will fatten up a liver
faster than fructose.
Okay, number four, fasting. What happens
when you fast both intermittently and
periodic prolong fasting is that you
give your body a chance to reduce
insulin and the body will then start to
go after fat reserves in your liver and
turn that into ketones. So it'll start
to tap in to the fat reserve finally
because you're not stimulating insulin
and then the amount of fat will get less
and less and less. So fasting is
essential if you are really serious
about getting rid of that fat in your
liver. Thanks for watching. Before you
go, real quick, I have a course entitled
How to Bulletproof Your Immune System.
It's a free course. I want you to take
it. And here's why. Here's you.
Here is your environment.
Everyone is focused on this over here.
avoiding your environment. But what
about here? What about strengthening
your immune system? That's what's
missing. This course will show you how
to bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own
immune system. I put a link down in the
description right down below. Check it
out and get signed up today.
Hey,